comment faire son travail de journaliste
sous les bombes comment continuer
d'informer quand sa propre ville est une
cible commun devient tôt aux porteurs de
guerre du jour au lendemain bonjour
alexander qui rit bonjour merci de venir
sur notre plateau vous êtes journaliste
vous êtes français et vous appartenez à
une équipe de journalistes à kiev le
fief est indépendante dans le travail
est en partie présenté dans ce livre
carnet de bord de la résistance
ukrainienne une série d'articles à vif
qui démarre du 24 février au 9 mai le 24
février date qu'on ne peut absolument
pas oublier avant toute chose alexandra
kerry racontez-nous votre 24 février le
jour l'est où les bombes ont commencé à
pleuvoir sur l'ukraine et bien le 24
février un peu un peu douloureux
évidemment réveiller à 4h30 5h30 du
matin
une ville une ville un peu va sous les
flammes et les murs qui tremblent c'est
assez particulier parce qu'on
n'imaginait pas on imaginait que ça
allait arriver mais mon immeuble on
n'imagine pas la violence et la
brutalité du choc de ce genre de réveil
et la veille vous avez passé une bonne
soirée oui soirée normale entre amis
entre amis vous vous réveillez sous les
bombes et très vite une question se pose
partir ou rester comment vous décider
je décide de rester parce que je
considère à ce moment là que c'est de
mon devoir de journalistes de rester
puisque depuis ça fait ça fait six ans
que j'habite en ukraine et depuis six
ans je me suis rendu compte que
l'histoire s'écrit zen s'écrivait et
s'écrit encore aujourd'hui sous mes yeux
donc je considère que c'était
effectivement un devoir de rester six
ans vous êtes là sachant que l'autre
guerre en ukraine a commencé en 2014
avec le donbass vous restez vous dites
pour dire la guerre comment est ce qu'on
dit la guerre quand on risque soit même
de mourir
c'est on oublie un peu ça finalement on
le met de côté parce que parce qu'encore
une fois j'utilise beaucoup ce mot de
deux missions et de devoirs mais mais
c'est comme bien l'idée d'un soldat qui
équipent rang qui prend les armes
finalement qui mais aussi de côté cette
vision de la mort qui pourrait arriver
parce que par définition dans ces cas là
la mort importe assez peu l'idée ça
reste de faire encore une fois son
devoir est d'informer et vous même vous
avez essayé vous dites aussi à plusieurs
reprises d'intéresser les médias
française voulait sur les enjeux de la
guerre dans le donbass qu'est ce qui
s'est passé je pense que en 2016 quand
je suis arrivé en ukraine ça intéresse
est assez peu les gens parce que c'était
une guerre de position une garde
attentes et qu'ils n'étaient pas
sensationnel comme l'a pu l'être en 2014
ou en 2015 n'est pas des images
frappantes
et même comme comment quand même
bienvenu un peu sans interrompre un
conflit gelé oui oui enfin jolie oui et
non dans le sens waouh ça continuait à
l'est les forces en présences continué à
se renvoyer de l'artillerie la la nuit
mais mais ça n'était pas assez jaloux
diraient intéressant pour les médias
français à l'époque vous dites à un
moment donné dans ce livre je ne suis
pas au reporter de guerre je suis
journaliste en zone de guerre c'est pour
la nuance la nuance c'est qu'un reporter
de guerre va sans doute chercher la
ligne de front on va chercher la guerre
alors que la guerre pour nous est venue
à nous et finalement ça va te
différemment dans le sens où on n'a pas
nécessairement un alors j'avais un peu
plus d'entraînement puisque j'avais
l'expérience du donbass mais mais on
appelle sûrement l'entraînement d'une
guerre qui vient justement faire
irruption dans notre vie quotidienne
alors c'est à partir du 24 février
l'équipe du quai f1 des plateaux va
compter tout à l'heure un quelle est
cette équipe d'où elle vient parce
qu'elle a quand même une histoire un peu
particulière
mais avant cela eu une petite précision
que vous apportez dans ce livre vous
avez décidé de de continuer de
travailler de vous battre avec votre
arme qui est celle d'informer avec une
conviction vous dites l'ukraine perd la
guerre les ukrainiens perdre l'ukraine
oui c'est une conviction qui est ancrée
et bien en ukraine depuis 2014 et et et
bien avant parce qu'il faut quand même
bien considérer que les ukrainiens aussi
on a à coeur de montrer et bien que la
russie aujourd'hui se comporte comme une
puissance coloniale vis-à-vis de
l'ukraine est comme une puissance qui
est qui et c'est justement de d'avoir de
récupérer dans son sang est bien un pays
qui cherche à vivre indépendamment et
d'une façon de prendre depuis eh bien
depuis 91 et depuis bien avant c'est une
guerre impérialiste
oui raconter la guerre la dir du point
de vue des victimes pas des baux
exactement exactement ici
si cette guerre pouvait changer quelque
chose on espère je pense que ce serait
ça pourrait être intéressant justement
que finalement et bien le cette vision
change et qu'on arrive et c'est bien
pour ça d'ailleurs que les journalistes
et que nous sommes restés en tant que
journaliste de plusieurs nationalités à
faire notre travail en ukraine c'est
peut-être effectivement changer cette
vision ne pas simplement avoir des
cartes tu as simplement avoir des
grandes batailles et les choses comme ça
mais au moins avoir les témoignages des
survivants et des victimes de cette
guerre le parti-pris alexander qui rit
on le comprend vous vivez ces événements
dans votre chair quasiment cependant
comme tout de même avoir la distance
critique du journaliste pour continuer à
faire son travail parce que quand même
cette distance critique elle est
absolument nécessaire à l'indispensable
dans notre métier elle et elle est
nécessaire elle est indispensable et
c'est parce que
nous avons conscience d'avoir ce prisme
d'avoir ce biais que justement on
développe encore plus de distance
critique est ce assez je sais je suis
d'accord c'est fondamental et c'est
crucial et c'est d'ailleurs bien pour ça
justement que nous faisons tout pour
parce que nous savons que nous avons ce
ce biais là et ce prisme là que nous
faisons tout juste bon pour respecter
cette distance critique à lucky est fait
d'eux des peines d'un casque sexe au
journal alors qu'hier dans la tendance
d'un journal qui a été créé par une
salle de rédaction avant tout qui a été
bien viré du jour au lendemain en
novembre 2000 21 par un
par un milliardaire qui possède l ancien
journal notre ancien journal le tiff
postes et en réponse parce qu'il fallait
une voix en anglais sur le cren en
réponse on a créé ce journal
à quoi ressemblait la liberté de la
presse
dans le cren de voler dix mille
wrésinski peut-être avant même déjà
parce que et on a cru comprendre que
c'est pas un long fleuve tranquille des
médias ont été fermés la liberté de la
presse avant la guerre ou semblait pas
qu'on en fait elle était déjà
problématique qu'il faut se souvenir de
dca de guéorgui gongadzé qui a été
retrouvé tué dans une clairière en 2000
il faut se souvenir de dca de pavot
charest m dont la voiture a été a
explosé en 2016 dans les rues de kiev
c'est les journalistes à une certaine
époque en ukraine en tout cas été
physiquement attaqués aujourd'hui en
tout cas jusque avant le 24 février
la pression sur les journées sur les
journalistes étaient plus financière que
ça c'est à dire que pour fermer un
journal l'idée c'était simplement de
traîner le rire les journalistes en
justice justement pour les empêcher de
faire leur travail comme vous dites ça
n'a jamais été un long fleuve tranquille
en revanche en revanche depuis maidan il
y à il y avait un support de la part de
la société civile pour les journalistes
on peut aussi rappeler alexander qu'eric
volodymyr danse qui lui-même disait
qu'il n'avait pas besoin de journalistes
puisqu'ils pouvaient communiquer
directement alors c'est plus andry board
and sons son ancien conseiller qui a qui
a changé puisqu'il a eu trois
conseillers depuis mais oui c'est vrai
que il avait ce rapport un peu un peu
problématique avec les journalistes et
je pense que la guerra a sans doute
changé ce rapport de communication avec
les journalistes ce livre carnet de bord
de la résistance ukrainienne renferme
une quantité d'histoires d'anecdotes il
est évidemment impossible de les
raconter tout certaines sont poignantes
d'autres sont drôles touchantes alors il
ya une histoire moi qui attire mon
attention c'est un jeu l'homme qui
habite kiev mais ses parents sont en
crimée ils ne veulent pas croire que la
russie attaque et l'ukraine et ce jeune
homme finit par dire je me considère
comme orphelins parce qu'il a perdu ses
parents c'est plutôt ses parents qui
l'ont perdue en fait parce que c'est pas
c'est pas le sait pas le seul cas dans
le sens où il ya toute une partie de de
l'ukraine justement qui est bien d'eux
mêmes de certaines familles qui ont qui
ont perdu 7,7 parentèle tout simplement
parce que en face si les gens qui ne
croient toujours pas que ça devait
arriver ou alors qu'il ne croit toujours
pas les raisons pour lesquelles celles
de guerre arrive c'est d'ailleurs aussi
pour ça que nous sommes là à faire ce
travail de conseiller il ya une vraie
fracture dans certaines familles sur les
raisons pour lesquelles ce déluge de feu
a été déclenché il n'y a pas de photo
dans ce livre pas de dessin non plus au
câble usb
parce que voilà on a on a des
photographes est évidemment de talent
mais parce que parfois les mots valent
puisque beaucoup beaucoup d'image je
crois alexander qui avait hier emmanuel
macron la fiole c'est mario draghi était
à kiev ainsi que le président roumain
klaus iohannis sme l'ukraine doit
pouvoir l'emporter a dit le président
français comment est-ce que votre
journaliste sur le terrain vous voyez la
suite et la fin de ce conflit
la fin comment elle va se dérouler je ne
sais pas je pense que c'est je crois
après c'est peut-être sans doute mon
parti pris je crois que l'ukraine
devrait l'emporter aussi parce que le
aujourd'hui l'ukraine défend l'europe
aujourd'hui la creg l'ukraine défendre
certaines valeurs et si l'ukraine tombe
l'europe tombe qu'est ce qu'il faut
souhaiter un journaliste de trainières
ou un journaliste étranger qui veut
aller couvrir la guerre en ukraine du
court en sachant que jusqu'ici les
journalistes ont payé un lourd tribut
oui à ce conflit récemment on a perdu on
confère à
à bfm tv
je pense qu'il faut souhaiter du courage
pense qu'il faut aussi leur dire de
faire attention dans le sang soit
aujourd'hui le craignent ce n'est pas le
nom base de 2016 c'est un conflit qui se
rapproche plus de la syrie ou de la knu
de tchétchénie en 2000
voilà c'est avoir conscience de
l'intensité de ce conflit je pense que
c'est fondamental merci beaucoup merci
alexander caïd est venu jusqu'à nos
journalistes au kef indépendante qui
publie la rédaction publie ce livre
carnet de bord de la résistance
ukrainienne s'est invité paris direct
merci à vous